lui qui avait raté quand même jamais
entendue mais non ça me dépasse je peux
vous dire un truc quoi les questions en
question ont été écrits de ce soir par
mois mais nathalie nguyen nouvel invité
mais ce que j'aime c'est sur nos
arguments surtout face à des partis par
bouffe ou troc caire après que
l'eurovision
quand on lui a demandé je sais pas si
vous avez vu chez vous le doigt et qui
ira et on a senti région pour faire un
petit jeu qui est capable de répéter un
des deux noms à part de ses filiales et
c'est pas grave ils sont dans les cas
tient malheureusement oui
tout ce qui touche copie tout ce en quoi
l'inquiéter vous et faites vous dans ma
chambre recul - jean-luc les 17 peur
question bonjour je m'appelle martin
j'aime beaucoup valérie bénaïm que je
trouve vraiment très intelligente et
surtout très joli
donc est ce que je pourrais devenir
chroniqueuse parce que vous voyez moi
aussi je peux dire n'importe quoi
ça démarre bien
ça c'est une très grande qualité vous
avez l'âge charmarty mais sachez que ce
n'est pas la seule nécessaire pour
entrer dans notre équipe
déjà pour entrer dans l'équipe il faut
avoir beaucoup d'autodérision pour
supporter les quêtes tiers par exemple
tout de suite un petit jeu pour tous
parmi ces quatre chroniqueurs deviner
lequel aime le moins bon travail
on est très très heureux d'être là
aujourd'hui émission vraiment formidable
parce que ya le retour des cafetières de
jean luc lemoine
un petit indice
ouais c'est vrai quand je vois cet
enthousiasme ne galvanise je me dis je
fais pas tout ça pour rien parce qu'il
faut le savoir si jean michel le
pouvaient ils m'empêcheraient d'en
livrer les off de l'émission de ces il
est très très angoissé et très angoissée
encore donc chaque semaine ils
échafaudent des plans
regardez
une idée un palet derrière la fortuna
poignet pour que ça reste bloqué et
l'embrassé une ou deux navettes vouloir
être embrassé
bah ouais
davantage quand on a un balai dans le
cul c'est qu'on peut faire le ménage
parmi les connards de l'équipe
mais bon ça va je les aime bien
jean-michel déjà parce qu'il est
intelligent
ah oui vous les prix pour ça papa la
base il intelligent c'est comme le sexe
de surveille et choisit les moments pour
dire du mal de moi tout de suite le prix
nobel de la semaine
tu penses que ça tombe bien c'est rouge
ça tourne bio
c'est rouge france a tourné caméra à ce
qu'il dit des saloperies rda monde
waouh est inquiétant ce fait elles sont
fous totalement
c'est ça surtout alors le cube valérie
je sais pas mais la caméra les marchés
alors nommé charles pas le seul à
saboter mon travail à ma grande surprise
je suis tombé là dessus quoi et pas dans
les quartiers attention est ce là tu le
gardes cela s'adresse à la c'est pour
toi qu'est-ce qui a pu mettre tous ces
gens dans cet état là non non est ce que
peut bien voir cyril à cacher comme vous
êtes deux à vouloir sa mort et ma
rubrique je vais être fair-play à la fin
des quatre hier je me vengerai mais que
d'un seul je montrerai soit la réponse à
cette question soit magnéto dévalorisant
pour jean michel a dévalorisé
je vous laisse réfléchir
vous avez tous leurs rubriques croyez
moi c'est toi tu es chez toi en
attendant revenons à la question
initiale quelles qualités faut-il avoir
intégré touche pas à mon poste je suis
là vous aussi venez il est sévère
ensuite on peut pas là on peut on peut
les enfants les enfants ils partiront
alors quand vous rentrez dans l'équipe
il faudra accepter la critique car cyril
est franc et direct c'est la foi sont
des fous et sa qualité
quand il a quelque chose à dire il le
dit sans détour exemple avec la petite
dernière de la bande caroline ithurbide
à 40 a été bien on va envoyer du bois
c'est bien moi je dis la vérité vous
coller
ils méritent un peu quand même
autre qualité pour être chroniqueur dans
notre édition il faut aimer ses
collègues aimé discuter avec eux comme
ici et nora et isabelle
là c'est beau à voir ces complicités
presque autant que celle de bertrand
chamerois et françois viaud le vendredi
déjà dit quand je viens à nîmes bébert a
souvent une oreillette pour être en
contact avec la régie c'est important
parce que tu sens que certains soirs il
en a gros sur la patate
mais moi je pourrais m
défonce le vieux
elle adore les matchs derrière bus
l'adorent alors j'aurai juste calme et
respectueux qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui demandent sur twitter dont cyril n'a
quand même pas montrer son zizi non ne
vous inquiétez pas c'est pas ça à la
passe a annoncé sa direction la place
pas des caméras contre angles ce qu'on
veut faire c'est à dire que dis je c'est
parce que bertrand avec françois viot
mais dès qu'il ouvre sa bouche françois
bertrand a l'air agacé c'était là bas
y'a plein de fuel trucks en fait qu'il
n'y en a que de plus en plus à paris 1
40 missions avec des gens simples
mon bébé alors je t'aime moi non mais je
veux dire la vérité je veux pas noircir
le tableau parce que à d'autres moments
bertrand et françois sont très complices
il rigole même ensemble non ça je
regardais voter pour lui dimanche vers
toi
ok d'enfer l'arrière les bons du cvec
colonel on perd j'adore moi mais je vais
moi aussi j'ai deux images si tu veux à
bertrand collot mais avec françois sauf
quand françois raconte ses anecdotes
ah ben moi j'ai reçu une fois en cadeau
de presse à s'exprimer avait pas le mode
d'emploi
oui bon
comme ça vous allez c'est que vous êtes
auto data vous venez méchant mais c'est
ça c'est ça jamais gérer autant jamais
jamais alors pouette dans l'équipe il
faut aussi savoir encourager ses
camarades quand ils font quelque chose
de bien
là c'était après la participation de
julien d'en haut sauf phrase parce que
j'en ai encore des avocats généraux
l'agent lui condamné l'attentât
c est ce que très content lui a volé en
éclats
non mais je vous rassure jean luc aubert
est très bien intégré dans les cours est
un bon chroniqueur bien évidemment
admiré et respecté syrie sort sans trop
en faire si des sinon ça se voit mais
c'est pas pareil c'était c'était du film
à rien mais créé il ya même pas y'a même
pas lu de personnes famille nasa soit là
ça se voit
là vous le faites exprès pour les quatre
roues non pas du tout ah bah non mais je
vous respecte depuis très longtemps
oui bah et on peut le dire ce qu'ils
font sacré comédien
en même temps comment ne pas admirer
cyril c'est cyril c'est la truculence la
richesse du verbe
là par exemple quelqu'un lui demander
pourquoi il portait une jolie bague
c'est pas beau ça
tu vas voir tu vas apprendre qu ça te
faire tout drôle
je prends tous les points de ta culotte
pour une bijouterie je peux dire qu'il
veut avoir des casses
je vais prendre ta culotte point de
bijouterie je peux dire tu ailleurs des
castrais on dirait du michel audiard ou
du rocco siffredi s'est pas inversée on
sait pas pourquoi ils portent de plus en
plus de bijoux
ouais enfin city et nora avait une
théorie et franchement on ne sait pas où
elle a été la chercher
ma maison ma douleur quand leurs états
d'âme
aux crétins d'abord hésitant
hier que dans a dit à dire que dans la
langue moins d'une demi heure là je vais
retrouver kenji on va être comme ça
dirt et à loos n'oubliez pas le concert
est ce que c'est si vous faites des
bisous ça va être gênant bon là c'est
elle rita nos versions asthmatiques
quand même une série c'est la générosité
permanente ils donnent ils donnent ils
donnent on sait pas qui mais il donne et
c'est pour ça que l'émission est de plus
en plus longues
pendant longtemps des huit s'est demandé
comment il pouvait l'arrêter pour
commencer leur film avant 23 heures et
bal lundi ils ont trouvé aujourd'hui
d'autres en direct dès 18 heures
logic immo.com recherche immobilière
c'est à ça dans le jargon la télé ça
s'appelle ta gueule réfléchir il est
comme ça c'est un enfant quand il aime
il ne compte pas sa passion en ce moment
c'est il l'a fait tout à l'heure les
imitations de jean marie le pen par
battre en chamerois l'aï lui demander de
faire jean marie le pen chantant la
fiesta ce qu'on peut toujours dire à
faire la fiesta qui jouent tous d'accord
grâce à cette imitation me jean marie le
pen me eddy mitchell le droit la tête la
plus bizarre de la semaine car quand
bertrand imite bat isabelle morini bosc
est à fond avec lui presque trop
franchement ça fait un peu peur jusqu'au
petit jour on ira faire la fiesta
j'y joue
oui
au revoir à l'oeuvre à londres on le
reprend alors ses touches en fait c'est
magique
on fait un petit point sur le dossier
final serré le jean michel est ce que
vous voulez est ce que vous voulez un
indice sur le contenu de la vidéo dont
vous avez honte oui non je reconnais pas
rester spectateur non juste un indice
oui c'est juste pour faire avancer votre
réflexion
bonjour je m'appelle je âmes
j'ai l'impression qu'au rentable cyril
hanouna aime bien parler de santé qui a
l'air très sympathique dans le je
voulais savoir est ce qu'il pourrait
nous le présenter
je vous laisse encore réfléchir bref
maintenant il ya deux semaines à nous
recevions les chanteurs du concert star
80 et notamment julie piétri interprète
du tube eve lève-toi et vous julie mais
oui bien sûr ça va marcher on le refera
le stade de france a fait avec m
ok mais ne vient que la france c'est
bien ce que je craignais rhinoise années
80 on en est où là dites moi non moi je
vois si on me dit souvent mais moi
j'aimerais bien tomber nous vous les
condamnez à la fin tout de suite ou pas
c'est ça la question c'est à dire non
pas ce qu'il en reste encore mais si
vous voulez on va ou non mais moi ce
qu'est ce que vous pouvez reprendre dans
un instant bah oui mais vous vous serez
encore là non je ne serai plus là ah bah
non
quoi c'est dommage qu'il ait dit ou
sinon on va directement la fin c'est
quoi la fin le choix entre jean michel
et vous cyril non je le dis il est
normalement je ne veux pas être la peine
je vais toujours au concert regardant
l'émission c'est julien courbet julien
est ce que vous préférez
ah mais moi je préfère que tu partes et
dès que tu serais parti en appartement
la situation des populaires que j'ai une
solution dite moi j'ai une solution
je trouve que cette vidéo vous devriez
la garder pour la dernière non non non
la dernière dans des quartiers ouais ça
me va c'est un pas très bien c'est signé
alors maintenant jean-michel on va aller
plus loin donc parce que jean-michel il
faut savoir là ils sont complètement
perdus évidemment un
alors le jean michel tout le monde sait
que jean michel se moque souvent du
physique de ses camarades
oui eh bien il peut il peut alors pour
les admirateurs de jean-michel tout de
suite une petite séquence sexy vous les
aimez mieux leur dis que je les aime je
n'en dise je prendrai soin d'eux
hier
et en bonus à est juste un bonus qui
avec jean michel il ya toujours un bonus
le bidon qui cherchent à s'évader plus
limitation du moteur de deux chevaux qui
ne débat pas
robin jeu je le redis je leur dirai ça
me fait rire ou dernière question pour
la route séparés bonjour je m'appelle
jean pierre tout le monde me dit que
j'ai le même humour que thierry moreau
voilà j'ai pas de questions j'avais
juste besoin d'en parler parce que j'ai
pas trop le moral